[Musique]
c'est ici qu'ils devaient se rassembler
les fierté montréal en a décidé
autrement le traditionnel défilé de la
fierté est annulé son préavis c'est la
pierre angulaire de la st moi ça me met
en colère c'est surtout fait qu'on
apprend seul
près de 100000 spectateurs et douze
mille participants étaient attendus
après deux ans d'absence la déception
est vive
j'ai su très des ce choc se fâcher
les bénévoles sans voix on appris
l'annulation comme tout le monde
on a juste une fois par année
c'est pourtant le manque de ressources
humaines qui aurait forcé la mise au
rancart du défilé c'est vraiment
que personne ne voit d'autre chose
d'avenant c'est un manque pur de
ressources 80 personnes manquaient à
l'appel pour assurer un défilé
sécuritaire en croire fierté montréal
c'est vraiment
pour moi c'est de l'incompétence
malheureusement je m'attendais pas à ce
qu'on annule la marche les organismes
sont convaincus qu'ils auraient pu
trouver des bras pour sauver les
célébrations bien que les bénévoles se
fasse de plus en plus rare vient
vraiment de faire un défi depuis la
cabine d'avoir les bénévoles soudée à la
cause
pour ces touristes de washington dc le
défilé s'avérait la cerise sur le sundae
un coup dur pour l'économie du village
ce restaurateur vienne perdre une part
importante de son chiffre d'affaires
match dommage pour montréal parce que ça
va faire un seul
mauvais goût le monde s'en viennent
d'ailleurs puis cinq ans à
l'échauffement
le spvm assure ne pas avoir participé à
la décision d'annuler les festivités
la ville de montréal partenaire de
l'événement demandera une reddition de
comptes mais si on avait été au courant
qu'ils manquaient des effectifs ou même
quoi que ce soit on aurait mis l'énergie
nécessaire je pense que c'est ça ma
frustration ce matin
[Musique]
avec ou sans défiler la communauté lgbt
montréalaise n'avait pas dit son dernier
mot c'est finalement l'initiative
d'organismes communautaires qu'une
marche a rassemblé plus d'un millier de
personnes dans les rues de la métropole
ici jean philippe jung radio canada
montréal